un conjunto de valores progresistas de izquierda, que dice:
"¡Puente levadizo! El mundo es un gran lugar.
La gente en Siria está sufriendo, hay que darles la bienvenida".
Y es algo hermoso.
Y estuve en Suecia este verano,
y si el discurso en Suecia es bastante políticamente correcto
y no se puede hablar de las desventajas,
excluye a una gran cantidad de gente.
Eso va a cortar el capital social,
esto hace que sea difícil tener un estado de bienestar
y que podría acabar como lo hemos hecho en EE. UU.
con una sociedad racialmente dividida, visiblemente dividida.
Todo esto resulta muy incómodo de hablar.
Pero creo que esto, especialmente en Europa y nosotros también,
tenemos que observarlo.
CA: Dices que la gente razonable,
personas que no se considerarían racistas,
pero moralmente personas decentes,
tienen una lógica que dice que los humanos somos demasiado diferentes;
que nos arriesgamos a sobrecargar
nuestro sentido de lo que los humanos podemos hacer,
mezclándonos con personas que son demasiado diferentes.
JH: Sí, pero se puede hacer mucho más agradable al paladar
diciendo que no se trata necesariamente de raza.
Se trata de la cultura.
Hay un trabajo magnífico de la politóloga Karen Stenner,
que muestra que cuando las personas tienen un sentido
de estar todos unidos, de ser todos iguales,
hay muchas personas predispuestas al autoritarismo.
Esas personas no son particularmente racistas
cuando sienten que no hay amenaza
en nuestro orden social y moral.
Pero si experimentalmente se hace
pensar que nos venimos abajo, que la gente es cada vez más diferente,
entonces son más racistas, homófobos y quieren echar a los desviados.
En parte se obtiene una reacción autoritaria.
La izquierda, siguiendo por la línea lennonista,
la línea de John Lennon,
hace cosas que crean una reacción autoritaria.
Ciertamente vemos esto en EE. UU. con la ultraderecha.
Lo vimos en Gran Bretaña, y en toda Europa.
Pero la parte más positiva de eso
es que creo que los localistas o los nacionalistas son en realidad la derecha.
Si uno acentúa nuestra afinidad cultural,
entonces la raza en realidad no importa mucho.
Así, un enfoque asimilacionista de la inmigración
elimina gran cantidad de estos problemas.
Y si uno valora tener un estado de bienestar generoso,
hay que destacar que todos somos lo mismo.
CA: El aumento de la inmigración y los recelos que despierta
son una de las causas de la brecha actual.
¿Qué otras causas hay?
JH: El siguiente principio de la psicología moral
es que la intuición es lo primero y luego el razonamiento estratégico.
Probablemente conoces el término "razonamiento motivado"
o "sesgo de confirmación".
Existen trabajos realmente interesantes
sobre cómo nuestra gran inteligencia y habilidades verbales
no han evolucionado para ayudarnos a encontrar la verdad,
sino para manipularnos para defender nuestra reputación...
Somos muy buenos autojustificandonos a nosotros mismos.
Y consideramos los intereses de un grupo,
no solo soy yo, es mi equipo contra el otro equipo,
pero si uno evalúa la evidencia de que su lado está mal,
simplemente no podemos aceptarlo.
Por eso es que no se puede ganar una discusión política.
Si uno está debatiendo algo,
no se puede convencer a la persona con razones y pruebas,
porque así no funciona el razonamiento.
Así que ahora, danos Internet, Google:
"He oído que Barack Obama nació en Kenia.
Voy a googlearlo, ¡10 millones de visitas! ¡Así era él!".
CA: Así que esto ha sido una sorpresa desagradable para muchos.
Los medios sociales a menudo se denominan tecnooptimistas
ya que existe esta gran fuerza de conexión que une a la gente.
Y ha habido algunos inesperados efectos contrarios.
JH: Eso es correcto.
Por eso estoy enamorado de la perspectiva yin-yang
de la naturaleza humana y de izquierda y derecha,
que cada lado tiene razón sobre ciertas cosas,
pero luego se ciegan ante otras.
Y la izquierda, en general, cree que la naturaleza humana es buena:
une a la gente, derriba los muros y todo estará bien.
La derecha, conservadores sociales, no liberales
los conservadores sociales creen que las personas pueden ser codiciosas,
sexuales y egoístas,
y se necesita regulación y restricciones.
Así que, si se derriban todos los muros,
y se permite que la gente se comunique con todo el mundo,
tendrás mucha pornografía y mucho racismo.
CA: Ayúdanos a comprender.
Estos principios de la naturaleza humana han estado con nosotros siempre.
¿Qué ha profundizado este sentimiento de división?
JH: Hay que detectar de 6 a 10 hilos diferentes todos unidos.
Voy a enumerar un par de ellos.
En EE. UU., una de las grandes, —de hecho, en EE. UU. y Europa—,
una de las mayores es la 2ª Guerra Mundial.
Existe un buen estudio de Joe Henrich y otros
que dice que si tu país estaba en guerra,
siendo jóvenes,
si se les examina 30 años más tarde en un dilema común
o el dilema del prisionero,
son más cooperativos.
Debido a nuestra naturaleza tribal, si Ud. es...,
mis padres eran adolescentes durante la 2ª Guerra Mundial,
y buscaban aluminio para contribuir al esfuerzo de guerra.
Es decir, todo el mundo se unió.
Y es así, estas personas siguen,
emprenden negocios y gobiernos,
toman posiciones de liderazgo.
Son muy buenos en el compromiso y la cooperación.
Todos se jubilaron en los 90.
Así que nos quedamos con el baby boom a finales de los 90.
Y su juventud la pasaron luchando dentro de cada país,
en 1968 y después.
La pérdida de la generación de la 2ª Guerra Mundial, "La gran generación",
es enorme.
Ese es un hilo.
Segundo, en EE. UU. es la purificación de los dos partidos.
Solía haber republicanos liberales y demócratas conservadores.
EE. UU. se vivió una mitad del siglo. XX. realmente bipartidista.
Pero por varios factores que hicieron mover cosas,
en los 90, había un partido liberal y otro conservador purificado.
Ahora las personas de cada partido son diferentes,
y no queremos que nuestros hijos se casen con ellos,
lo que en los años 60 no importaba mucho.
La purificación de los partidos.
El tercero Internet, el estimulante más sorprendente
para el razonamiento a posteriori y la demonización.
CA: El tono de Internet ahora es bastante preocupante.
He hecho una búsqueda en Twitter sobre las elecciones
y he visto dos tuits, uno al lado del otro.
Uno de ellos, en contra de una foto de grafiti racista:
"¡Esto es repugnante!
La fealdad que nos ha traído Trump a este país".
Y el siguiente es:
"Página dedicada a Crooked Hillary. ¡Asqueroso!".
Esta idea de "asco" es preocupante para mí.
Porque uno puede tener una discusión o un desacuerdo sobre algo,
y lograr enojarse con alguien.
El asco activa las cosas a un nivel mucho más profundo.
JH: Así es. El asco es diferente.
Enojo..., ya sabes tengo hijos...
Se pelean 10 veces al día,
y se quieren 30 veces al día.
Acabas de ir y venir: te enojas, no estás enojado;
estás enojado, no estás enojado.
Pero el asco es diferente.
El asco muestra a las personas como subhumanas, monstruosos,
moralmente deformes.
El asco es como tinta indeleble.
Hay investigaciones de John Gottman en terapia de pareja.
Al fijarnos en las caras, si uno de la pareja muestra asco o desprecio,
eso es un indicador de que se van a divorciar pronto,
mientras que si muestran enojo, eso no predice nada,
porque si uno gestiona la ira bien, es realmente buena.
Esta elección es diferente.
Donald Trump personalmente usa la palabra "asco" mucho.
Es muy susceptible a los gérmenes por eso el asco importa mucho,
más para él, eso es algo único en él.
Pero a medida que nos demonizamos entre nosotros,
a través de una visión maniqueísta,
es decir, que el mundo es una batalla entre el bien y el mal
y mientras esto está aumentando,
es más probable decir no solo que los otros están equivocados,
sino que son satánicos,
que son repugnantes, que son asquerosos.
Y no queremos nada con ellos.
Y creo que lo estamos viendo, por ejemplo, en el campus ahora.
Vemos la necesidad de mantener a la gente fuera del campus,
silenciarlos y alejarlos.
Me temo que toda esta generación de jóvenes,
si su entrada a la política implica mucho asco,
no querrán estar involucrados en política con el tiempo.
CA: ¿Cómo podemos hacer frente a eso?
Asco. ¿Cómo se desactiva el asco?
JH: No se puede desactivar con razones.
Creo...
Estudié el asco muchos años y pienso mucho en las emociones.
Y creo que lo contrario del asco es realmente el amor.
El amor, como...
El asco bloquea, crea fronteras.
El amor disuelve los muros.
Por eso las relaciones personales, creo,
son probablemente los medios más poderosos que tenemos.
Uno puede sentir asco por un grupo de personas,
pero luego conoces a una persona en particular
y descubres que es preciosa.
Y gradualmente la antigua visión se aleja y también se cambia tu percepción.
La tragedia es que los estadounidenses solían estar mucho más mezclados
en sus pueblos los de derechas y de izquierdas.
Y ahora existe esta gran brecha moral,
hay mucha evidencia de que nos mudamos para estar cerca de la gente
políticamente afín a nosotros.
Es más difícil encontrar a alguien del otro lado.
Así que están allí, muy lejos.
Es más difícil conocerlos.
CA: ¿Qué le dirías a los estadounidenses,
a la gente en general,
sobre lo que debemos entender sobre cada uno
que pueda ayudar a replantear
este instinto de asco?
JH: Sí.
Un dato fundamental a tener en cuenta,
existe un estudio del politólogo Alan Abramowitz,
que muestra que la democracia estadounidense se rige cada vez
por el denominado "partidismo negativo".
Eso significa que piensas: Muy bien hay un candidato,
te gusta el candidato, votas por el candidato.
Pero con el aumento de la publicidad negativa
y los medios sociales y todo tipo de tendencias,
cada vez más, la forma cómo se hacen las elecciones
es que cada parte intenta hacer al otro horrible, tan horrible,
que tú votarás por mi candidato por defecto.
Y así, se vota más y más en contra del otro lado
y no a favor de lo nuestro.
Hay que tener en cuenta que, si la gente es de izquierdas,
piensa: "Yo solía pensar que los republicanos eran malos,
pero ahora Donald Trump lo demuestra.
Y ahora describo a todo republicano con los atributos
que pienso de Trump".
Y eso no es siempre cierto.
Por lo general, no están muy contentos con su candidato.
Son las elecciones partidistas más negativas en la historia estadounidense.
Así que hay que separar primero los sentimientos sobre el candidato
de tus sentimientos sobre las personas que eligen una opción.
Y entonces hay que ver que,
dado que todos vivimos en un mundo moral separado,
—la metáfora que utilizo en el libro es que todos estamos atrapados en el "Matrix"
o cada comunidad moral es una matriz, una alucinación consensual.
Y si estás dentro de la matriz de color azul,
todo lo que es convincente del otro lado...
son trogloditas, racistas, son las peores personas en el mundo,
y tienes todos los datos para respaldar eso.
Pero alguien en la casa contigua a la tuya
vive en una matriz moral diferente.
Ellos viven en un videojuego diferente,
y ven un conjunto completamente diferente de hechos.
Y cada uno ve diferentes amenazas para el país.
Y lo que he comprobado estando en el centro
para entender ambos lados es que ambas partes tienen razón.
Hay muchas amenazas en este país,
y cada lado es constitucionalmente incapaz de ver todas.
CA: Entonces, ¿dices que necesitamos un nuevo tipo de empatía?
La empatía es tradicionalmente:
"Oh, siento tu dolor. Puedo ponerme en tu piel".
Y lo aplicamos a los pobres, los necesitados, los que sufren.
Por lo general no la aplicamos a aquellos que percibimos como otros,
o por los que sentimos asco.
JH: No. Eso es correcto.
CA: ¿Qué aspecto tendría la construcción de ese tipo de empatía?
JH: En realidad, creo...
La empatía es un tema muy, muy candente en psicología,
y una palabra muy popular de la izquierda en particular.
La empatía es algo bueno y empatía por las clases preferidas de víctimas.
Por eso es importante empatizar
con grupos que la izquierda cree que son tan importantes.
Eso es fácil de hacer, porque se obtienen puntos por eso.
Pero la empatía realmente debe contar, si se hace cuando es difícil.
Y pienso...
Hemos tenido un período de 50 años para tratar con nuestros problemas raciales
y la discriminación legal,
y fue nuestra prioridad durante mucho tiempo
y sigue siendo importante.
Sin embargo, creo que este año,
estoy esperando que la gente vea
que tenemos una amenaza existencial en nuestras manos.
Nuestra división izquierda-derecha, creo,
es la brecha más importante a la que nos enfrentamos.
Todavía tenemos problemas de raza, género y grupos LGTB,
pero esta es la necesidad urgente de los próximos 50 años,
y las cosas no van a mejorar solas.
Así que debemos hacer muchas reformas institucionales,
y podríamos hablar de eso,
pero eso es una conversación larga y retorcida.
Pero se inicia con la gente entendiendo de que este es un punto de inflexión.
Y sí, necesitamos un nuevo tipo de empatía.
Debemos darnos cuenta de que
lo necesitamos en nuestro país,
y esto es lo que tú necesitas, aunque no quieras.
Levanten la mano quienes no quieren pasar los próximos 4 años
enojados y preocupados como. lo estuvieron el último año.
Así que si quieren evitar eso,
lean a Buda, a Jesús y a Marco Aurelio.
Tienen todo tipo de consejos sobre cómo abandonar el miedo,
replantear las cosas,
para no ver a los otros como enemigos.
Hay mucho escrito en la sabiduría antigua para este tipo de empatía.
CA: Mi última pregunta:
En lo personal, ¿qué puede hacer la gente para ayudar a curar?
JH: Sí, es muy difícil decidir superar los prejuicios más profundos.
Hay un estudio que revela
que ahora los prejuicios políticos son más profundos y fuertes que los raciales
en el país.
Así que creo que hay que hacer un esfuerzo, eso es lo principal.
Hagan un esfuerzo para agradar a alguien.
Todo el mundo tiene un primo, un cuñado
alguien que está en el otro lado.
Así que, después de estas elecciones,
esperen una semana o dos,
ya que probablemente alguno de Uds. se sentirá muy mal,
pero esperen dos semanas y ofrezcan diálogo.
Y antes de hacerlo,
lean "Cómo ganar amigos e influir sobre las personas" de Dale Carnegie,
(Risas)
Lo digo totalmente en serio.
Aprenderán técnicas, si comienzan con reconocimiento,
si comienzan diciendo:
"Sabes, no estamos de acuerdo en un tema,
pero una cosa que realmente respeto de ti, tío Bob..."
o "... de los conservadores, es..."
Y se puede encontrar algo.
Si Uds. comienzan con reconocimiento, es como magia.
Es una de las principales cosas que he aprendido
y que aplico en mis relaciones humanas.
Todavía cometo muchos errores estúpidos,
pero ahora soy muy bueno disculpándome,
y reconociendo que alguien tenía razón.
Y si uno lo hace,
entonces la conversación va muy bien, y, de hecho, es muy divertido.
CA: Jon, es fascinante hablar contigo.
Realmente parece que la base donde estamos es un terreno poblado
de profundas cuestiones de moralidad y la naturaleza humana.
tu sabiduría no podría ser más relevante.
Gracias por compartir este momento con nosotros.
JH: Gracias, Chris.
JH: Gracias a todos.
(Aplausos)